後ろ側からいいだけ
こんなにも僕は
明るい顔になれるんですいやーこれじゃあはじめした上ですもう気付い
傷ぐっとかそういうレベルじゃないですね
ぶー分
壁紙を変えました
[音楽]
はやっとですよ前まではレンダーだったんですけども揃い目名像ですねシンプルに見え
つつてちょびっとだけコートがあってねさりげないオシャレというか俺さぁ
おしゃれとができるようなさーーん俺さ何度おこされとかっていう
シンプルかつ何見たい何というかこうやっぱ
おしゃれな俺がね押されの頂点なんだよああやマーキングですよゴット
ちょっと自民シンプルが好きな定番結局は白が一番いいんですよ
誰も言わなかったんですけど壁紙今までずっとレンダーだったんですけど
よかったのは最初の一週間だけですお皿になった気がしたんだいつもレンガといっしょ
の最高の気分だけどすごい飽きちゃった呆れてが軽バン金暗くなるんですよ壁紙ガチャ
いるだけですごいなんか気分が下がってもうねぼく年頑張って猫を現実に振る舞ってた
んですよは見えてエッ
嘘ですそんなそんなそんなくらいかないけどまぁちょっと圧迫感はありましたね
私はにした方がなんかすごい子爽やかな気分になります
俺じゃ沢谷とこいしょ爽やかボーイジャズへ
マキオズるって言って込んだからねこの北へ上の瓶で行くを止めます原画はインパクト
あったけどやっぱりノーマルが一番よ
最高だねぇ
壁の張り替えがに今日のあさイチにあって実は目指した部屋汚くてある程度きれいに
しようと思って片付けてたんですよなんで僕は今寝てなくて
に本日は手伝ってすごい緩い状態なんですけど伝わります画面から声があんまり出て
ないね無音する今こうやって喋ってること自体が不思議なくらい今でもいいんですけど
俺だときで目を気がめちゃくちゃいいんですよ
荻田氏
がこんな感じっていう自分現在まで弱らせてるって俺の寝起きの強さを今日見せようと
思います壁紙後は明るいからね
さわやかな状態で飛行機は bose aq 5号の4時で濡らしてみよう
今なるわけよ
これはでどんどん強くなっていくパターン
ああ
これはうるさいね
これ感じねな音がどんどん大きくなってですよ
じゃメーカー覚めるだめだよく2分言え出ててもこのなんか時計の音を聞いた瞬間術
察知して瞬間的にそれを止めに行けるんですよなんで今日は今から出ますロフトの上に
うるさい路その上に溶け大糸クンてタイマーなってから何秒後にそのタイマーを決めに
いける書くといういわゆる病気反射神経ゲームみたいな実は
ただ寝たいだけですいいじゃあねて動画も撮れるからねこんなにいいことないよこたつ
とこのソファー最強の組み合わせますよ
ガチャに出るからね一瞬で調理時間な見とけよ
[音楽]
バッハ
4日
[音楽]
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
ます
tee
さあ